- Alright, y'all, we are back
and we've got Maestro Kaiso on violin,
hanging out with band, y'all.
(audience cheers)
Yeah, Maestro.
Our next guest, though,
is one of the most
prolific children's writers
of this generation.
So far, his "Diary of a Wimpy
Kid," lean in for this folks,
this series has sold more
than 290 million books.
(audience cheers)
What?
And, has been turned into seven movies.
I mean, it's, like, I don't know a family
that doesn't have these
books in their house.
His latest book in the collection,
"No Brainer," is out now.
Everybody say hello to
Jeff Kinney. (claps hands)
(audience cheers)
So, there our 18 books are the original,
that's the original series, right?
- Yeah, that's the main series, yeah.
- Yeah, we have those.
we were discussing, I have
all these in my house.
- That's awesome.
- Yes.
they're so massively popular.
Like, where did this, the
origin of all of this, start?
- Well, I wanted to be
a newspaper cartoonist,
but that didn't work out for me,
so I'm.
- I'm glad it didn't.
- Oh, I appreciate that.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- So, I tried for a number
of years to get syndicated.
It didn't work out, nobody liked my stuff.
And, I was keeping a journal
at the time, and I thought,
you know what, this format
of text and some pictures
is really appealing. Nobody's
ever really done this before.
So, that's how I got the idea
for "Diary of a Wimpy Kid,"
and Greg Heffley.
It took me eight years to put it together.
And, then I found a publisher
right here in New York.
- Oh my gosh. I mean, what?
The lucky publisher that
said yes to that idea.
I'm, like, good lord.
So, you're Greg, right?
It's a little bit of Greg?
- Yeah, unfortunately.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Not
unfortunately! So relatable.
- Well, I've got more hair
than him, but he's got a,
he's a complicated character.
He's, kind of, a mass of
contradictions and imperfections.
Just like I was as a kid,
and just like I am now.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And, everything's just
exaggerate for comic reasons.
- Yeah, I mean I think a lot
of people relate to that.
That's why kids like it,
too. Like, it's relatable.
- [Jeff] I think so too.
- Yeah.
- If you look at Greg on the
cover of the books, he's like,
he looks like he's having
a hard time of things.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And, I think if I put
a smile on his face,
and made him look brave or strong,
it wouldn't be the same book.
I think you need to know
that other people are having trouble too.
- Yeah, I think that
that's very comforting.
So, where do you write,
where do you go to?
'cause I write songs, like,
anywhere. Where do you write?
- Well, believe it or not,
I actually do a lot of my
writing in the cemetery,
(chuckles) which seems dark.
- What?
- Yeah, it seems a little
bit dark, but, yeah,
there's a picture I think.
(audience laughs)
But, my kids were doing,
you know, remote schooling
during the pandemic, and I
needed a quiet place to work.
So, I got in my car, got a
blanket, and some Skittles,
and some Double Stuffed Oreos.
- Oh my God, you're a college kid.
I love this right now.
That's amazing, okay.
- So, my books are really
fueled on that kind of food.
It's sad.
- Oh my God.
That's why it's so relatable
to kids, that's amazing.
So, this new book is
called "No Brainer," right?
- Yeah.
- So, what's different about this one?
- This one's about,
it's like a satire of the
American education system.
It's about Greg's school getting shut down
because they do poorly on
their standardized tests.
But, then the school demands
that if they don't, you know,
raise their grades with less money,
then they're going to be closed for good.
So, that's what the book's all about.
- Oh, that's awesome.
- And, I also touched on
things, like, you know,
school budgets, and in-school advertising,
and book banning too.
I satirize that because of
course it's a hot topic.
- Yeah. So, tell us about,
it's the "No Brainer Tour,"
right? And, it's helping
schools and libraries?
- That's right. We're
helping schools, libraries,
and, well, school libraries and,
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- Community libraries.
We're giving away a
hundred thousand dollars.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- We're doing this game show
format, which is really cool.
It's different than a
regular author event.
And, we're rewarding librarians,
spotlighting librarians,
because now, more than ever,
librarians need to be
cherished and uplifted.
- Yeah!
(audience claps)
And, my kids, I love the library
at our school, growing up,
but my kids, that's the
thing they talk about,
the little reading nooks that
they have at their school,
they love it!
It's, like, escapism for them.
- It's so important
for kids of all stripes
to be able to see themselves
in the pages of a book.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- Represented in a positive way.
- Absolutely. Well, you're awesome!
Thank you for being on the show.
- Well, thank you very
much. I appreciate that.
- Such a fan. I'm a bigger fan now.
We need a quick break, everybody,
but we have a nine year old here
who says he is Jeff's
biggest fan. Like, biggest.
He has no idea Jeff's here.
So, Jeff's gonna go hide,
and come out for one giant surprise.
It's gonna be really great.
(audience claps)
So, Jacob, thank you for being here.
And, also, are you a fan
of books, you like reading?
- Yep.
- Yeah?
Is "Diary of a Wimpy Kid,"
one of your favorites?
- Yep.
- Yep. (laughs)
So why do you love these books so much?
- I like them because it's
about a middle school kid
who's misunderstood by his parents.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Also, I like that the character,
that the main character
Greg relates to me a lot.
He's not that good at sports.
He doesn't like to sweat.
(audience laughs)
He likes video games. He's
really good at video games.
- Yeah, I love video games too.
So you, do you know anything about,
I think Jeff is the writer, right?
Of "Diary of a Wimpy kid?"
So, do you know anything
about Jeff Kinney?
- Not much about his personal life.
(audience laughs)
But, I know that he is
always thinking up good ideas
and putting them into writing.
- Yeah, is that something that you think
you'd be interested in
doing when you grow up?
- Yep. I've already made some books.
Like.
- What?
- [Kid] Yeah.
- That's crazy cool.
- What are they about?
- Well,
one of them is called "John
versus the Glipper Glorps."
- Yes!
- And, the Glipper Glorps are these aliens
who kidnapped the entire town.
- [Kelly] (gasps) I
love, I would read this.
- And, and, and John and his hamster
have to save the entire town.
Also!
- This is a great idea!
(audience cheers)
That's an awesome idea.
So, you wanna be an
author when you grow up?
- Yep.
- Yep. "Yep!" I love it.
Well, I have to let Jacob
in on a little secret,
because we invited you here
to review "No Brainer,"
but that wasn't all.
We actually have a surprise for
you. Do you want a surprise?
Do you like surprises?
- Yes!
- Okay, okay. That's good.
'cause it was happening regardless, Jacob.
(audience laughs)
So, the creator of the "Diary
of a Wimpy Kid," series,
Jeff Kinney, is here
and wants to meet you.
Is that cool?
- Yep.
- Look at you right now!
Come on out, Jeff!
(audience cheers)
Come on over.
- How are you doing? Good to see you.
(Kelly laughs)
Jacob, this is awesome.
I can't believe I'm getting to meet you.
You're like a legend,
everybody knows about Jacob.
I've heard all about your
stories, and you're like an expert
at "The Diary of Movie
Kid" books, aren't you?
- Mhm.
- This is pretty cool.
This is cool. Look at this, we're.
- You completely pivoted
his entire physicality.
(everyone laughs)
- He's like, "I'm not sure about this."
- He said, "And, who's she?" And then.
I love it. No, stay there!
I love it, I love it.
Is that a good surprise?
- Yep!
- Yeah, yeah? (laughs and claps)
So, Jeff, do you want to
say anything to Jacob?
- Yeah, first of all,
thank you for being a fan,
but I also wanted to say I have a studio
in Plainville, Massachusetts,
in my bookstore,
on the top floor.
It's really cool, it's really colorful.
It's like the center
of the Wimpy Kid world.
And, I would like to invite
you and your family up
to spend time with me in the
studio, draw on my computer,
and we'll have some pizza,
and talk about books,
and talk about your books.
Is that sound like a good idea?
- Yep.
- All right.
(all clap)
Great, all right, let's seal on the deal.
- Oh my god, I love you two!
Y'all should do something together.
Well, we need a break.
I don't want a break,
'cause it's so special.
But, pick up Jeff's
latest book, everybody,
"Diary of a Wimpy Kid, No Brainer."
It's out now, and everyone
here is going home with a copy.
(audience cheers)